i focusing quite heavily on ed miliband
by saying in this campaign the personal
is the national but he's now got
positive ratings even higher than you in
one poll today do you think it's
backfiring is that why you're not
talking about him today no not at all
I'm talking about this every day which
is there's a choice of leaders and
there's a choice of teams to run this
country and there's the my team which
has produced the jobs and the growth and
the long term plan that's working and
there's Labour's leader and Labor's team
that would take us back to square one
with more borrowing more taxes more debt
more unlimited welfare all the things
that got us into a mess in the first
place and I'll be talking about that the
day before polling day just as I am
today because that's what this election
is about it's choosing the team to run
the country do you like it do you find
it quite hard to you know be quite
personal I don't really know him to be
honest we've faced each other across the
despatch-box that promises questions but
we have a very profound disagreement
about the right way to run our country I
say stick with the plan that's
delivering the jobs and the growth he
has opposed every single step that we
took to put that plan in place he
opposed every efficiency every change to
welfare every reduction in taxes are
plans to allow people to buy their own
home is opposed every steps i think is
profoundly wrong and i think that would
be the wrong team or the wrong person to
run our country and in the end whether
you call it personal or not elections
are about choosing the team to take the
country forward now I'm not saying we've
solved all the country's problems but
this country is definitely stronger with
more people in were almost 2 billion
more people in work than when I became
Prime Minister fantastic thanks very
much